bom eu vou começar fazendo duas
perguntas pra vocês
a primeira é se vocês conhecem a cidade
bom é aqui que eu vivo desde que eu
nasci em alvorada e alvorada é uma
cidade brasileira que fica localizada no
rio grande do sul e é bem próxima da da
capital daqui de porto alegre
e pra quem já conhece alvorada quando eu
falo o nome dessa cidade que palavra vem
vem à mente de vocês
então eu fiz essa mesma pergunta
só que pra moradores da cidade ea
resposta que eu tive foi a seguinte
para eles as palavras que mais
caracterizam alvorada são palavras como
assalto sujeira medo abandono e
insegurança e descaso vergonha
mas mesmo nessa pesquisa outras palavras
apareceram só que de maneira menor
palavras como perseverança trabalho e
esperança e hoje aqui eu vou contar
sobre como através do meu desenho eu
deixei de ver o dourado daquela forma
negativa e passei a vê la assim de uma
maneira positiva bom desde pequena
sempre gostei de desenhar a que eu
trouxe os desenhos que eu fiz quando
tinha cinco anos nas agendas de casa e
ainda pequeno já que já com dez anos uma
das coisas que eu adorava fazer
quadrinhos
eu imprimi numa folha de ofício vários
quadrados e tentava criar nesse formato
uma história em quadrinho e já mais
velho ainda pra faculdade
como eu moro em alvorada e estuda em são
leopoldo
eu precisava pegar um ônibus e um trem e
durante esse trajeto do trem e comecei a
a desenhar os passageiros
esses difícil foi muito importante pra
mim o desejo muitos muitos
passageiros e comecei a me ver como um
desenhista ea gostar do meu trás e pegar
a prática desse esse exercício desse
trabalho nasceu o meu primeiro projeto
artístico um recorte no metrô onde eu
pegava os desenhos e misturava com a
foto de onde os passageiros estavam
sentados com algum pensamento que eu
pensava ali no momento indo para a
faculdade e ainda na faculdade eu tive a
oportunidade de fazer um intercâmbio
através ciência sem fronteiras da
espanha e na espanha eu estudei artes e
aprendi nesse neste estudo mas sobre
desenho e pintura e aproveitei pra
ampliar esse meu projeto recordes no
metrô com os novos lugares que estava
conhecendo e com as novas técnicas que
eu estava aprendendo na espanha eu tive
a oportunidade de conhecer vários vários
e vários lugares e quando voltei ao
brasil percebi que eu não conhecia minha
própria propriedade e logo que eu
cheguei aqui eu tive oportunidade de
trabalhar como diagramador no jornal
local de alvorada e diagramadores
chargista e é importante a charge porque
através dela eu comecei aproxima mais
dos problemas de alvorada e eu também
precisei começar a refletir sobre eles
mas eu não estava satisfeito eu queria
conhecer ainda mais a minha cidade
então eu tive a idéia de começar a
entrevistar moradores de alvorada e e
transformar essas entrevistas em
histórias em quadrinhos e deu muito
certo esse projeto eu e durou um ano e a
cada 15 dias
ele saía neste jornal e ao todo
entrevistei 23 moradores da cidade por
exemplo entrevistei aelita
que tem 85 anos e contou a história da
família dela e como essa história se
cruza com o nascimento da cidade
eu entrevistei o seu luiz que vem chuvas
em alvorada mais de 30 anos e sustentou
a família inteira com esse trabalho e
entrevistei o bento que também trabalha
há mais de 30 anos só que vendendo
revistas
entrevistei o morador de rua josé que
contou a história dele de amizade com
aquele cachorro tito e entrevistei a mãe
lê que falou sobre a história dela ea
história da religião dela entrevistei
também o josé damião que falou sobre a
história dele que se cruza com uma
tragédia que aconteceu em alvorada que
foi a enchente em 2015 e ele salvou mais
de 120 cachorros nascente e foi um
aprendizado muito grande conhecer essas
histórias e as outras que eu não pude
mostrar aqui porque porque eu cresci
tanto artisticamente quanto pessoalmente
mas acima de tudo eu comecei a então
conhecer a minha cidade eu por exemplo
com jorge da lagoa
aquele da falta anterior e eu eu eu
aprendi sobre o patrimônio ambiental que
a morada possui com a bernadette eu
aprendi sobre a riqueza arquitetônica de
alvorada com ele trata sobre a
importância de preservarmos o o passado
da cidade com josé o título a o valor de
uma amizade mesmo em situação estão
adversas com a rita recicladora eu
aprendi sobre a luta por uma vida digna
através do trabalho aqui a rita com a
sua história publicada e uma das maiores
emoções que eu tinha durante esse
projeto era era ver esses moradores de
alvorada
suas histórias valorizadas e e sentiu o
quanto isso fazia bem para a autoestima
dele sabe como eu disse no total
entrevistei 23 moradores e agora com o
apoio da prefeitura essas 23 histórias
vão virar um livro
na verdade já vi já virou livro 500
livros que você doados nas escolas
municipais de alvorada para que para que
os alunos cresçam conhecendo a história
de onde elas vivem e que tem um orgulho
de de viverem ali junto com esse
trabalho eu também estou saindo por
alvorada e tirando fotos da cidade e
transformando essas fotos e ilustrações
e a idéia é fazer 21 atrações pra que
ela se transforme em 20 cartões postais
para que os moradores de alvorada possam
enviar para outra cidade com orgulho o
lugar de onde elas vivem e vocês se
lembram da da primeira imagem que eu
mostrei então esse aqui é um desenho
daquela vista e ele é muito
significativo para mim porque foi o
primeiro desenho que eu fiz de alvorada
e eu também antes de começar esse
projeto tinha preconceito com a minha
cidade mas através dos desenhos de certa
forma eu tô redesenhando a cidade dentro
de mim e espero conseguir redesenhar a
virada para outras pessoas também
e se me fizessem a pergunta que eu fiz a
vocês que eu fiz uma pesquisa sobre com
que palavra eu definiria a morada
eu usaria alguma daquelas três palavras
que apareceram no no início que aparecer
timidamente na minha pesquisa porque a
através da história de vida das pessoas
eu aprendi a ver o morada como lugar de
perseverança
trabalho e esperança muito obrigado